bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on vient de le voir
ces manifestations partout en france les
puits à paris quelle lecture faites vous
de ces mouvements de contestation qui
semble prendre de l'ampleur
oui tout à fait on observe une
mobilisation qui est très importante
pour un pour un mois de juillet et qui
en fait est une composition très
hétéroclite et on commence à le
remarquer dans les manifestations
notamment ce samedi où on a plusieurs
cordes d'âgés différents 1 2 les
barreaux florian philippot avec son
parti et patriote et un autre plus tôt
couleurs gilet jaune et en fait non pas
petit à petit se rendre compte que ce
mouvement de contestation est très
diversifiée où on peut retrouver des
antilles pas sanitaire des antilles vax
des anti vaccination obligatoire et les
personnes qui sont davantage en rupture
avec la parole emmanuel macron et qui
voient ici l'opportunité de le combattre
plutôt sur le plan politique
donc ma selle grande diversité le fait
qu'on observe une gilet jaune isation
entre guillemets du mouvement et pas
étonnante puisque en réalité le laverait
la fracture vaccinale à laquelle on
observe qu'ils étaient détaillés dans
dans le monde
s'il fit le fracture entre des
territoires qui sont plutôt périphérie
contre des territoires plutôt
métropolitain une fracture entre les
communes pauvres contre les communes
riches et une dernière fracture entre
des régions du nord du nord ouest contre
les régions du sud-est et donc en fait
on on regroupe deux des quatre fractures
qui avait été mise en relief par le vent
des jets les jeunes c'est à dire une
fracture sociale une fracture
territoriale à laquelle les jeunes ont
ajouté deux autres factures c'est de
l'impuissance de l'état et une fracture
identitaire
donc c'est normal qu'on retrouve
finalement des gilets jaunes dans ce
type de mouvement et vous glissez
d'urgence sanitaire a justifié selon les
autorités l'application de ce pass s'est
rapidement trop vite peut-être c'est
peut-être pour ça que certains
réticences aubrac
nous on pense que manuel mac ont fait
une erreur d'analysé
d'un point de vue des priorités la
priorité si on veut éviter un recond
finement c'est d'éviter la saturation
des hôpitaux et qui
potentiellement saturent les hôpitaux
c'est principalement les personnes à
risque qui ont le plus de chances
d'avoir de contracter des formes graves
de la maladie et d'être d'être amené en
réanimation
donc nous on penser que la priorité
c'était en fait la vaccination
obligatoire des personnes à risque ce
qui a évité de devoir mettre en place un
pass sanitaires et de créer une forme de
société à deux vitesses une france à
deux vitesses
parce qu emmanuel macron a déjà déclaré
en décembre dernier que le vaccin ne
serait pas obligatoire pour la
population générale
il ne peut plus utiliser ce levier pour
éviter la saturation des hôpitaux
l'idée c'est d'éviter d'un point de vue
de la communication d image désastreuse
qu'on a eue sur les masses ou le masque
était inutile tu es devenu obligatoire
en population générale donc manuel
maintenant est bloqué il n'a plus qu'un
seul levier c'est la question du passage
du ter qui a beaucoup de défauts parce
qu ils fracturent la société davantage
qu'il a réuni fille est en fait il peut
se retrouver dans une position où il va
devenir le chef d'un camp plutôt que le
chef du pays en prenant parti pour une
partie de la population qui sera vacciné
et en en mettant en marge d'une partie
de la société
d'autant que par ce moment là même si la
vaccination progresse c'est pas pour
autant que la contestation va baisser
puisque dans les manifestations et dans
les cortèges on retrouve aussi des
personnes qui sont vaccinées donc
politiquement la situation est très
inflammable pour emmanuel macron et le
tournant le tournant sera plutôt à la
rentrée quand les personnes vont revenir
de vacances
est ce que le pass alternant paraîtront
les mesures de restriction ce qu'on
considérait dans leur quotidien comme
justifier comment elles vont vivre avec
ce nouveau dispositif
et c'est à ce moment là où l'on verra si
l'opinion publique qui pour l'instant en
réalité et pas trop porté sur la
question est-ce qu'il va pencher plutôt
du côté des manuels macron plutôt du
côté des manifestants
donc tu as moins que la question des
enfants quand on on va finalement
s'apercevoir que parce que des
personnages qui ne sont pas vaccinés
en fait on est amené avec les deux plus
en plus les enfants c'est sur ces points
précis où le ou l'opinion publique que
tomber d'un côté de l'autre et rendent
la situation très difficile pour
emmanuel macron glisser le gouvernement
le répète en vacciner
car sinon j'en veux dire familièrement
c'est le confinement qui vous pend au
nez pour certains c'est tout simplement
la réalité sanitaire pour d'autres ça
s'apparente plutôt à du chanteur est ce
que vous les comprenez ce que vous
entendez cette réaction
la difficulté pour emmanuel macron c'est
tout son pari c'est atteindre un taux de
la création très élevé et en fait son
seul levier puisqu'il veut pas utiliser
la vaccination obligatoire sauf sur
certains segments de la population comme
les soignants et les personnes qui sont
en contact avec les populations plutôt à
risque c'est d'être extrêmement clivant
de tenir des positions de plus en plus
forte pour essayer de convaincre et de
plus tôt même contraindre les personnes
un peu hésitantes à se faire vacciner et
dans le même temps il va radicaliser ses
oppositions avoir des opposants qui va
être de plus en plus radicaux parce que
ça va durer dans le temps et que la
parole emmanuel macron on va polariser
l'opinion plutôt que d'essayer de
prévenir les français donc c'est pour ça
qu'on assiste à ces positions où les
critiques vont être de plus en plus
virulente et la difficulté pour emmanuel
macron c'est qu'il a annoncé qu'il
voulait faire campagne
lors de son discours du 12 juillet sur
un slogan le slogan de françois
mitterrand la france suivie et il fait
tout sauf réunir les français
puisqu'elle est plutôt dans une démarche
motive
oui crée des distorsions dans la société
la fracture et essayer de dresser une
france contre une autre celle des
vaccinés contre celle des dons vacciner
pour essayer de convaincre au maximum
est de contraindre les gens à la
vaccination générale à devoir du think
tank millénaire merci à vous d'avoir été
intéressante sur arte france